Thank you for having me, I appreciate it.
It is a pleasure to be in a kitchen with you, sir.
I'm absolutely honored.
What are we making today?
I can't wait to learn from you.
I mean listen, there's no better way
to commemorate yourself than a backyard burger.
You know what I mean, and it's not just any burger.
I love kebab, and I mean,
I've been doing these lamb burgers,
but I'd never put it on Wonder Bread with mayo and ketchup,
but let me just show you how to do this.
Alright, I love a mortar and pestle.
I get so excited.
You put the cumin seed right into the mortar and pestle
it's also, it's very interactive.
I love this, I love interactivity.
Um, there's that
So you throw the, you throw those spices
that you could put it in there.
Just mash it up good.
Mash it up real nice.
So what you do is now you add that to your meat,
pop it in there.
I'm going to put a little glove on,
cause I'm going to touch, I'm tempted to touch.
All right.
So now you just mashed the patty down a little bit.
We already have one made over here.
I kind of over mashed it.
That's all right, you could never move a mash, you know.
That's nice, so while that's going,
you take your Wonder Bread and you just lather it,
slather it with a nice helping of mayonnaise.
So this is going to go down for a little bit.
You know what?
That looks good.
I, I'm a hot mess in the kitchen Action.
It's all about being calm.
You have to have some music on, some vibes,
you know what type of vibes I'm talking about.
And I don't know if we can talk about
what I'm talking about, but I would just turn, we're good.
I know what you're talking about actually.
Don't you worry?
I'm right there with ya.
Beautiful. See, no, you're good.
Yep. I'm fine.
Okay. For in the meantime, we do have
two pre-made burgers right here.
You could just slather that, put it down,
then give it a little extra ketchup, you know.
There it is!
(speaking with mouths full)
You see that drip?
Damn, I haven't had that flavor in like two weeks.
Oh!
Holy cow, that is so good!
Action, you are my kind of man.
Oh my God.
I just want to stand in this stance and eat this with you.
I'll do that.
I'm in like a, almost I'm in like a squat, strong stance
By the way, can we get in like the birthing bear,
like bear down position and eat again?
Yes. I'll stand like this all day.
God, I just, I don't know why,
but this was what I had the urge to do.
Thank you, Action Bronson!
Go to the drewbarrymoreshow.com for the full recipe.
I can't, I'm just, I'm too excited.
I love you, thank you so much.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)